here with exclusive reaction tonight
four of the dnc is donald trump jr
executive vice president of the trump
organization all right don first
i want to play this moment from joe
biden tonight
this is a life-changing election
this will determine what america is
going to look like for a long long time
character is on the ballot compassion is
on the ballot
decency science democracy they're all
on the ballot that sounds like a plan
that was really the theme of the week
though no policy just
decency overload um the meaning is that
your dad doesn't have any of that
decency or compassion thing does this
work don
i i don't think so i think the american
people expect results from their
politicians and joe biden has been a
50-year swamp creature literally
he was elected into dc office in his 20s
so now half a century later laura he
managed to read a speech on a
teleprompter he refuses to answer
questions from the american people or
journalists uh he's been hiding in a
basement but now he's going to also
change things
i really don't think that anyone
believes that i don't think that joe
biden's ever been inspiring in his
career and i don't think tonight was any
different
but again if he can read a speech on a
teleprompter you would think he'd be
able to get in front of
the american people you'd think he'd be
able to do an interview with a real
journalist
where they're not giving him
pre-scripted answers he's reading the
answers off of a teleprompter
you'd think he'd be able to do that
after half a century in washington dc
but he can't the reality is you've seen
this week they heard jill biden and
michelle obama and every day the next
morning well maybe that person should be
running for president
they're not inspired by joe biden nor
should they be because he hasn't done
anything to deserve
inspiration through a very long and very
swampy career
yeah my my line for the last four days
has been it's too bad
he and obama weren't in charge for eight
years because then they might have done
all this cool stuff i mean
but but he did beat expectations don i
mean people were expecting him to flub
every line and have a senior moment and
it's just as a delivery and i don't
think it was devoid of most
any policy other than universal masking
um
but he delivered he delivered a a good
speech and it was
you know for what he was doing very
emotional the emotional stuff
you know walk down memory lane and so
forth it was it was fairly well
he also lied you know he brings back you
know the democrats only you know their
easy button going back to the lie about
charlottesville
he talked about being tough on china joe
i mean you're going to be tough on china
now
joe spent his entire career building
china when joe started pushing and
shilling for them to get permanent
status in the world trade organization
china had an economy the size of the
netherlands
hunter biden you know he didn't talk
much about hunter strangely enough i
wonder why
uh hunter biden took 1.5 billion dollars
from the chinese government to the
average person in a fund just so you're
aware
that's 30 million dollars a year in fees
in fees 30 million a year annual you
think joe's going to get tough on china
now
joe fought for nafta joe fought for tpp
all of the deals that literally
destroyed
the american dream our only export under
joe biden's
50-year tenure has been that american
dream to countries that hate our guts
and have been manipulating us for
decades donald trump's the first guy to
stand up to those people
he's the first guy to actually get deals
done whether it be with china
whether it be a peace deal in the middle
east where's joe biden been
you're right he was in control for eight
years with barack obama why didn't they
do any of these things
joe biden knew how to fix anything why
didn't he tell barack obama how to do
why didn't they get it done you know or
barack obama was keeping it secret
to give to joe for later use that's when
he was right that's what it is yes it
was going to be their secret so now
that's after eight years of failure
after eight years of stagnation
uh you know you're gonna now you're
gonna get to listen to michael bloomberg
who spent a billion dollars to win
american samoa
i don't know probably not gonna take his
advice either um the elusive hunter
biden since you mentioned him don
he did make an appearance tonight take a
look
i'm hunter biden and i'm ashley biden
joe biden is our dad
and bo is our brother we want to tell
you what kind of president our dad will
be
he will be tough and honest caring
and principled don g notice how
they were trading words until the end
when ashley said
caring and principled did yeah because i
don't want hunter to say that
i don't think hunter after hiding from
uh you know spousal support
uh child payments etc etc
again not to mention the crooked ukraine
deals the crooked chinese politicians
the chinese government investing 1.5
billion dollars with him though he was
not actually an investor before
i don't think hunter is going to talk
much about character in these things the
reality is whether it's hunter
whether it's joe biden's brother whether
it's his sister
they've all spent their entire lives
profiting of joe biden's
taxpayer-funded offices that's all they
know
and that's honestly why they haven't had
the decency to step in and say joe you
know what maybe it's not your turn maybe
it shouldn't be you
uh they should have done that during the
primary but they can't because they have
nothing else
it's the epitome of the swamp and that's
what this election is going to come down
to
it's going to be the swamp versus
freedom in america it's going to be
socialism as you've seen with the bernie
sanders
joint unity platform on joe biden's
website
it's going to be socialism versus
freedom versus the constitution
all of those things that the democrats
don't believe so much in you also didn't
hear
because again they brought up the hoax
nonsense uh quote that they've
manipulated and the media has carried
their water with
for months about charlottesville notice
they didn't talk at all about the crime
in democrat-run cities
burning looting beating people in the
streets
joe's never even denounced that the
democrats haven't even denounced that
it seems as though they're almost
tacitly accepting of it
laura those are
all democrat cities and they have been
in some cases in over a century
and instead the references to the cities
was always in terms of wasn't it
inspiring that these new
versions of john lewis he's not
protesters
don't run down cars they don't burn down
housing projects
they don't loot gucci stores to get a
new handbag or purse
or belt that's not peaceful protesting
and yet
between the dnc and their marketing wing
the mainstream media
i heard a lot about peaceful protesting
i believe someone called it the summer
of love
give me a break i hope that good
god-fearing american people see through
this nonsense
because that's the problem that we face
we are in an uphill battle in the sense
that
it is so biased it is so flagrant the
media has just totally abdicated their
responsibility
to be arbiters of of truth uh without
bias
to be activists for the left that
regular people aren't consuming that
sort of news i mean joe biden he's gonna
get tough on china i mean
you it's laughable it's beyond it's
beyond laughing
it's a china question alone he should be
able to do an interview with someone
like yourself
or someone who's not gonna spoon feed
him
questions that he already has the answer
to that he's miraculously
leading off of a teleprompter they'd
think they would do that but i don't
think they will and no one's going to
push for it
don and yes or no answer do you think he
is going to debate your dad yes or no
i think he'll try to get out of it
however he can okay don great to see you
tonight thanks so much